nos invités stéphanie pour ça que
secrétaire adjoint du syndicat
gilet jaune et maxime thiébaut doctorant
en droit auteur du livre à un gilet
jaune vers une démocratie réelle
bonsoir à vous merci à d'être en direct
avec nous ce soir
alors on l'a vu que c'était compliqué
pour les gilets jaunes de manifester
comme ça allait quand même depuis
beaucoup de samedi maintenant il ya une
marche des pouvoirs donc a été retoqué
par la préfecture de police
il ya finalement ils ont quand même
marché parapluie à la main
dans quelle mesure ces restrictions elle
entache le mouvement des gilets jaunes
stéphanie pour ça qu alors on avait
déclaré en fait une marche des pouvoirs
en effet on avait déclaré le 7 décembre
et l'idée c'était de marchés sur les
devoirs de la constitution c'est-à-dire
le pouvoir judiciaire conseils d'état et
constitutionnel
le pouvoir législatif en défilant devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et le
pouvoir exécutif en défilant devant
matignon et ensuite en arrivant sur le
rond point des champs elysées et après
en terminant en beauté sur la place de
l'étoile bon le parcours a été refusée
par par didier lallement
sans surprise mais il a été refusé très
tard donc du coup ça nous a laissé très
peu de temps pour saisir le tribunal
administratif ce qu on a fait quand même
on a été audiencé on a plaidé
et finalement la juge des référés a
confirmé l'interdiction de manifester
nous a laissé ce petit bout de manif
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui c'est à dire la
place du palais royal jusqu'au pont des
heures ça fait 3 100 mètres ça fait 5
min de marche
là on a mis une heure parce qu'on est
allé très doucement mais c'est un tout
petit bout et c'est pas c'est pas du
tout ce qu'on avait demandé quoi mais
donc c'est représentatif un peu de ce
qu'on vit de ce qu'on vit depuis le
début c'est à dire que les lieux on voir
les représentants du peuple sont
déconnectés du peuple et on n'a même
plus le droit ne serait ce que de s'en
approcher pour manifester pacifiquement
et exprimer librement ses opinions
maxime thibeault vous pensez que
ces restrictions elles sont susceptibles
d'inhiber le mouvement des déchets les
jaunes ces restrictions alors moi j'ai
pas lu l'ordonnancé de la juge des
référés du tribunal illustrative de
paris il faudrait voir sa motivation
réelle lorsque assez marrant c'est que
malgré tout les gilet jaune on puisse
rendre devant le conseil d'état qui est
quand même le juge administratif
peut-être il a voulu reconnaître qu'il
était tolérant des manifestations mais
en étant un peu plus sérieux c'est vrai
qu'on on s'inquiète quand même de ces
atteintes liberticide en permanence sur
le droit de manifester on se souvient
que pendant la première phase ii du
confinement du mois de déconfinement il
a fallu que le conseil d'état
interviennent pour dire au gouvernement
que le droit de manifester est un droit
constitutionnel et qui devait être
garantie donc moi je suis très inquiet
par le fonctionnement en fait d'
emmanuel macron et de son gouvernement
qui veut que il a raison en tout il a
raison sur tout et que tout le reste
n'est une opposition de complotiste
n'est une opposition de gens qui n'ont
rien compris ou qui ne sont rien et je
reprends ici sa sémantique
donc moi je suis assez inquiet par cette
dérive liberticide que l'on connaît
depuis le début du quinquennat d
emmanuel macron et qui se confirme dans
la rue malgré tout avec des forces de
l'ordre qui sont plus que présente
parfois même pour des manifestants qui
sont assez peu présent on a vu
aujourd'hui
malgré tout il y avait assez peu de
gilets jaunes alors c'est vrai que les
jets les jeunes on marchait dans paris
avec bien encadrés avec une présence
massive des forces de l'ordre dé gilet
jaune qui se mêlent aux manifestants
opposés à la loi de sécurité globale
avec ce fameux article 24 certains
verront peut-être derrière cette
démonstration de solidarité de
l'opportunisme
que leur répondez-vous stéphanie pour ça
de l'opportunisme non alors nous notre
revendication pour déclarer cette marche
des pouvoirs c'est s était pas seulement
la loi sécurité globale à laquelle nous
sommes opposés totalement ya pas que
l'article 24 qui va pas dans cette fois
la loi est en entière est à mettre à la
poubelle à mon avis mais en fait nous
nos revendications elle et elle était
simple c'était la destitution des
manuels macro fins et les revendications
qu'on a envoyé du helmand dans la
destitution des manuels macro la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale et
l'instauration du rich dans une nouvelle
constitution
voilà donc c'est ambitieux joue la corde
mais c'est le régime
voilà c'est le résultat de deux ans de
manifestations et de mépris en face on a
effectivement un mur en face de nous
avec un gouvernement et puis des médias
dominants qui nous méprisent nos
caricatures et il faut que ça s'arrête
ces lois liberticides elles sont juste
inacceptables donc on va pas piller on
va continuer et on re déclarera la cette
marche des pouvoirs et on la déclarera
avec suffisamment d'antécédents ce pour
cette fois aller jusqu'au conseil d'état
après le tribunal s'est alors ça va vous
avez un peu d'écrits les les
revendications c'est souhaité elle est
un peu les revendications premières
d'ailleurs du mouvement notamment le
rique maxime thibeault sur cette
question de l'opportunisme des gilet
jaune
vis-à-vis de cette loi sécurité globale
qu'en pensez vous ces intérêts sont là
qu'on parle du rite on parle des
réformes institutionnelles parce que les
gilets jaunes j'ai écrit sur sur les
gilet jaune
il faut distinguer les joules les gilets
jaunes devenu un parti politique ou une
formation politique un syndicat une
association ce qu'on veut peu importe
qui ont des revendications à un
programme d gilet jaune à la base c'est
à dire de tous ces français qui étaient
dans la rue jusqu'à peu près mi décembre
2018 et qui eux étaient sur une phase
assez simple c'est les classes
populaires et classes moyennes sont
oubliés par les élites et il faut un
moment que la démocratie réapparaissent
après ça s'est politisée donc c'est vrai
que si vous demandez une manifestation
en disant voilà destitution macron on
souhaite la dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale en fait on souhaite
complètement changer la constitution
il est certain que on peut avoir des
craintes un peu plus grosse de la part
du gouvernement
mais moi ce que ce que j'ai apprécié ans
première c'était les revendications
premières vous vous souvenez des
mouvements disent les jaunards que
manifester chaque samedi nations
premières elles sont apparues lorsqu'on
a fait naître des leaders lorsque les
médias ont cherché des leaders bfm tv
tous ces news tous les mystream qui
voulaient casser les gilets jaunes ont
cherché des leaders afin de pouvoir
trouver des personnes à identifier et
avoir des idées derrière mais à
l'origine de gilet jaune c'est
simplement une contestation populaire
c'est une jacquerie qui était globalisé
sur l'ensemble du territoire national et
qu'il ne voulait surtout pas de
représentant donc en fait tout
représentant des gilet jaune par
définition trahissent l idée même d
gilet jaune qui ne voulait plus de
représentants mais démocratie réelle
fondée sur le tirage au sort fondé son
référendum
moi je distingue les gilets jaunes à la
base de la formation politique de la
politisation des vidéos mais c'était
très beau derrière les gilet jaune est
derrière tous les mouvements de
contestation qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a des gens qui ont le
courage de dire ça ne va plus on est
dans un système mondialisé quitte à ce
qu'ils cassent les plus pauvres qui créa
si les classes moyennes et aujourd'hui
il faut revenir à la base faut défendre
la solidarité faut défendre la
fraternité faut réformer nos
institutions en ce qu'elles sont
mauvaises et ça c'est louable et moi ce
jeu ce que je déplore aujourd'hui c'est
une résignation en fait assez globale
des français qui ne bougent plus trop
alors que pourtant on a des atteintes
qu'ils sont complètement inadmissible à
l'aller
berthe et notamment aux périodes de co
vide que la loi de sécurité globale
permettra de porter atteinte aussi à nos
libertés fondamentales on à l'article 24
on a aussi la question des drones
on a la question des polices municipales
qui vont monter en puissance et moi ça
me gêne parce que la police elle doit
être nationale pourrait faire respecter
le principe d'égalité de tous les
citoyens
donc moi je je je suis content de voir
des français qui qui se révoltent au
sens démocratique du terme c'est-à-dire
qu'ils manifestent même si je pas
d'accord à toutes les idées parce que je
suis très inquiet on regarde toutes les
appartements l'avenir des gilet jaune
pour l'année qui s'annonce stéphanie
pour ça que vous êtes secrétaire adjoint
du syndicat gilet jaune donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya quand même une structure
qui se met en place au niveau des gilet
jaune
parlez nous un peu de justement de cette
structuration si elle existe
véritablement ont parlé des leaders tout
à l'heure alors oui la structure elle
existe véritablement en fait nous on est
bon je dis pas je pense que c'est une
équipe on est syndicaliste révoltés
depuis des années et on est indépendants
aussi depuis des années c'est important
de le dire parce qu'on fait partie
d'aucune centrale connu c'est à dire cgt
cfdt fo toutes celles que vous
connaissez et donc on a créé la la
structure syndicale gilet jaune à la
demande de certains gilet jaune parce
qu'on est on est un peu des spécialistes
du domaine et donc on était capable de
le faire
et l'idée c'est de ces deux c'est un
outil en fait c'est pas du tout la
solution évidemment c'est un outil pour
rentrer dans l'est dans les boîtes pour
rentrer dans les administrations créer
un contrepouvoir solide et structurée et
aussi apporter aux gens qui le souhaite
parce que les gilets jaunes sont quand
même très maltraité depuis le début du
mouvement
c'est une répression qui est pas
seulement policière elle est allée
financière elle et les législatives elle
est judiciaire
donc pour pour aider pour pour aider ces
personnes il faut aussi une structure
juridique un peu solides le syndicat
c'est une possibilité de faire ça c'est
à dire qu'avec les cotisations des
adhérents parce que ce sera notre seul
revenu non refusera toutes les
subventions de l'état ou des patrons si
vous restez libre et indépendant mais
avec les cotisations des adhérents on
pourra mutualiser les moyens et
notamment et apporter une
une structure juridique pour pouvoir
aider les personnes en difficulté merci
beaucoup à vous en tout cas maxime
stéphanie pour ça que secrétaire adjoint
du syndicat gilet jaune et maxime active
au doctorant en droit auteur du lean je
le rappelle gilet jaune vers une
démocratie réelle merci à vous deux